this is an incident that unfolded just
after seven o'clock in this park in the
center of reading we understand that
multiple people were stabbed the
information that we are now receiving as
three people have died from their
injuries a number of other people are
being treated in hospital for their
injuries ear ambulance and other
emergency responders were very quickly
on scene and tending to those who'd been
stabbed but it's clear in addition to
those who are believed to have died a
number of the other people who were
injured have been quite seriously
injured this evening our source has told
me that authorities are working under
the assumption that this incident is
terror related we are expecting some
kind of statement from the police a more
substantial statement from the police
probably within the next hour or so of
course as I say it unfolded at 7:00
o'clock this evening police have been
trying to piece together the exact
circumstances around what is now
believed had been a terrorist incident
we know that one man has been arrested
now the press association is reporting
that this man was a libyan national we
have not been able to confirm that line
for ourselves but that is being reported
by the Press Association at this hour we
have been able to confirm through our
own sources that three people are
believed to have died and as I say that
significant development that it is being
treated as a terrorist incident now of
course that has all kinds of
implications for the authorities in
terms of how they deal with this
incident now because any terrorist
related incident has a potential to have
a wider threat alongside it so as a
matter of urgency the investigators from
the southeast terrorism unit along with
those of course at Scotland Yard will be
delving into this man's background
trying to
find out who exactly he is whether he
was known to the police and security
services sadly of course we have seen
with other terrorist attacks that the
majority of those who carry out
terrorist attacks are known to the
authorities because these incidents
rarely happen in isolation in the sense
that someone is often on a journey into
extremism heading down towards violent
extremism and they will often come
across the radar of the police and the
security services we don't know at this
stage whether this man who is in custody
was known to police and security
services but even if he was they have a
judgment call to make to determine
whether anyone should be worthy of a
full investigation about the potential
actions but the the urgent priority
actually will be to determine whether
there are other individuals out there
who know this man who associate with
this man who may have had knowledge of
what the person that carried out the
stabbing attacks was planning whether
there is any wider threat in terms of
the potential for other attacks we know
of course a terrorist threat level at
the moment has been reduced to
substantial it was reduced to
substantial last year having been at
severe for a number of years severe of
course means that a terrorist attack is
highly likely it was at severe in 2017
when we had those five terrorist attacks
in the space of just one year but the
Joint Terrorism analysis Center who look
at the the threat picture that's out
there they involve of course members of
the security services and other security
officials determined that it should be
reduced to substantial still meaning
that an attack is likely but not highly
likely as the severe definition
determined so that of course will be
reviewed as well in the coming hours if
they get information of the potential of
other others out there or potential for
other attacks then of course the threat
level would be
increased but there is no indication
that that is on the cards at this stage
were still in the very early stages
offer police and counterterrorism
investigation as I said we are hoping
within the hour to hear a bit more from
Thames Valley Police perhaps from
counterterrorism policing as well about
the ongoing investigation the Press
Association reporting that the man in
custody is a Libyan national and we are
reporting of course that they are
treating this as a terrorist incident
one other point of clarification that's
worth getting out there Thames Valley
Police have tweeted this evening to say
that these multiple reports on social
media suggesting that there is some link
to black lives matter are erroneous
there was a black lives matter protest
that took place in that area earlier
today as there has been in previous
weekends as well but they say there's
absolutely no length that they can see
to the black lives matter protests are
worth getting that out there and
certainly with the confirmation that
this is being treated at this stage they
believe as a terrorist incident it would
seem to back up what the police are
suggesting there as well the injured
have been taken to area hospitals we
know that the Royal Berkshire Hospital
in Redding has received a number of
casualties at least two of those
seriously injured are in resuscitation
resource at the moment in the accident
and emergency department being treated
by those doctors at the scene so some
significant injuries in addition to the
three people who died you can see in
that image that we're showing you now
two ear ambulances among those that
responded to the scene to this park in
Redding to pick up the most seriously
injured in addition to these air
ambulances there were paramedic and
senior paramedic officers that attended
the scene as well and in the early
minutes after this incident armed police
were involved as well because of course
we had a suspect at large at that time
we understand that that suspect was
arrested nearby now there are other
images circulating of an armed operation
at a block of flats on the edges of this
park we haven't had it officially
confirmed that that is linked to the man
you can see the images there of the
block of flats but certainly the
suggestion from journalists down there
the scene in reading is that the arrest
which involved on police at this block
of flats in Redding is linked to the
incident and is linked to the man who is
now in custody who is a see the press
association is reporting is a libyan
national the Home Secretary of course of
the Prime Minister and others being kept
up to speed with what is happening Priti
Patel said earlier this evening that she
was very concerned at the reports coming
out similar sentiment from the prime
minister who has issued his thoughts
with those who have been caught up in
this attack and thoughts with the police
and first responders who have been
dealing with what is clearly a very
troubling traumatic incident in this
March return